cannabis had a breakout 2020. legal
sales across the u.s hit a record 17.5
billion dollars
a 46 increase from 2019 according to a
new report published by bdsa
a cannabis sales data platform 14 states
allow for adult cannabis use while 36
allow for medical sales
most of the sales growth came from adult
use markets especially mature markets
like colorado
where sales grew by 26 percent to reach
2.2 billion dollars
oregon saw sales hit 1.1 billion dollars
a 29
increase over 2019. emerging markets
like illinois which expanded its medical
cannabis market to include adult use
sales last year
saw a rise of million dollars
this was the largest dollar gain in the
us and illinois is currently doing more
than one billion dollars in sales
california the country's largest
cannabis economy at 3.5 billion dollars
increased sales by 586 million dollars
while florida saw an increase of 473
million dollars
according to experts at bdsa three
things contributed to the industry's
growth last year
the kobit 19 pandemic more customers
entering mature markets like california
colorado
and oregon and states like illinois and
arizona establishing new adult use
markets
another factor driving the industry's
growth is a simple one
more people are consuming more cannabis
than before
about 30 percent of consumers surveyed
by bdsa said they shop for cannabis
products
more often while 25 percent of consumers
say their cannabis usage has increased
since before the pandemic
in colorado where market penetration is
greatest in the country
48 of coloradans imbibe cannabis
delivery companies
also made a killing last year as they
capitalized on the pandemic
bdsa found that the number of americans
using cannabis delivery
increased 25 but most of the cannabis
industry is still in the black market
illicit cannabis sales are estimated to
be more than 100 billion dollars each
year
but the legal industry is slowly
catching up by 2026
bdsa predicts the legal u.s cannabis
market will reach
41 billion in annual sales roughly the
size of the craft beer industry
me